la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités est l'invité d'auditions
publiques bonsoir madame buzyn et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à l'invitation des chaînes
parlementaires du figaro et de la fp au
programme de l'heure qui suit pour vous
question bien sûr de nos journalistes
d'abord déjà ici présente anne pascale
reboul et mathilde de si haut qu'on soir
mesdames
et puis il y aura tout à l'heure où
brigitte boucher et oriane mancini et
puis interpellation surprise totale
heures de la députée socialiste gisèle
biémouret et de la sénatrice centriste
élisabeth doineau que vous connaissez
déjà car il suit les questions de santé
notamment d'abord madame bien votre
commentaire sur l'itinérance mémorielle
entamé donc par le président de la
république aujourd'hui il a surtout
évoqué les dangereux relents des années
30 en europe
est ce aussi le cas en france selon vous
je pense que c'est un contexte général
nous sentons évidemment montée des
populismes les nationalismes le repli
sur soi dans un certain nombre de pays
européens avec des décisions qui
inquiète sur la liberté de la justice ou
des médias dans certains pays
et puis au delà de nos frontières au
brésil tout récemment bien sûr que ce
relent nous le sentons d'ailleurs
quelque part là je dirais le nombre de
d'actes de violence vise à mi-vie zazie
des homosexuels des actes
d'antisémitisme tout cela fait penser à
effectivement un moment où la société
peut basculer et la société française
oui et je pense que
le récent sondage demandant aux français
s'ils seraient pour un régime
autoritaire et qui montre que 41% des
français ne serait pas opposé à un
régime autoritaire montre peut-être que
les français ne font plus la distinction
entre l'autorité qui est naturel et
nécessaire dans un état et
l'autoritarisme les régimes autoritaires
où les libertés sont bafouées et où en
fait les libertés régressent et ça c'est
très inquiète heureusement des analystes
est-ce que vous l'auriez fait cette
comparaison entre deux périodes
historiques est années 30 est
aujourd'hui qui sont des périodes très
différentes
je pense que l'histoire ne se répète
jamais tout à fait de la même façon mais
oublié l'histoire c'est aussi prendre le
risque de passer à côté d'événements qui
doivent interpeller et je trouve que
cette visite mémorial du président
république justement elle incite à cette
reconquête de l'histoire il y a un
magnifique livre de christopher claque
car qui s'appelle les somnambules qui
explique comment les pays européens ont
avancé sans se rendre compte vers la
guerre de 14 chacun dans son schéma
politique chacun regardant ses petits
intérêts immédiats en faisant fi du
risque historique de la guerre eh bien
ils font toujours se reposer cette
question là à tout moment de l'histoire
notre démocratie sont fragiles elles ne
sont pas inscrits sur des millénaires
alors justement vous avez évoqué une
résurgence d'antisémitisme
certains bureaux d'élèves de fac de
médecine et de pharmacie manifesterait
une fascination morbide pour le nazisme
selon l'union des étudiants juifs de
france est-ce que vous en avez
connaissance est ce que vous envisagez
des mesures alors en l'occurrence c'est
la ministre de la recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
qui s'est attelé à ce dossier elle a été
rencontré des étudiants
je crois qu'elle a été au congrès des
étudiants juifs de france justement pour
parler des mesures qu'elle souhaitait
prendre dans les universités contre ce
relent d'antisémitisme
connaissances vous rend comme j'en
connais fort bien sûr j'en ai eu des
naissances j'en ai quand même temps que
vous la presse quelque part papa pas
plus tôt mais je pense qu'il faut
toujours redouté ces actes
d'antisémitisme
ils sont toujours la traduction d'une
société qui va mal à une société qui va
mal donc on l'entend en le voit emmanuel
macron se posent en rempart mais c'est
un bon c'est rare encore quand même
fragile plus est ils étaient sept au
total dans l'opinion et cette popularité
même son isolement en europe
alors ils sont dix alors vous parlez
deux choses différentes
son isolement en europe ça n'est pas
vrai il n'est pas isolé en europe il a
fait beaucoup de voyages à l'étranger
récemment en espagne au portugal dans
les pays de l'est et il est très
soutenue par salons en france
en france il est quand même est-ce que
sa faiblesse justement dans l'opinion ne
favorise pas les extrêmes
au contraire on voit aujourd'hui un
sondage qui montre par exemple que le
rassemblement national est au même
niveau que la république en marche aux
européennes oui ça fait longtemps que le
rassemblement national fait toujours des
scores importants dans les élections que
les français considèrent peu impactante
pour vous vraiment mal aux remparts à
moi je le pense pas souvent président de
la république a une vraie vision de ce
que doit être la reconstruction d'une
europe nouvelle plus proche des citoyens
une europe du progrès une robe de la
protection sociale est ce que la france
a fait en europe sept dernières années à
la suite du discours du président de la
république à la sorbonne où il avait le
tracé la voie justement de cette réforme
européenne
eh bien la france a gagné un nombre de
batailles considérable qui protège les
citoyens je pense à la directive sur les
travailleurs détachés que les français
attendaient et que nous avons réussi à
faire modifier
je pense au travail sur le droit
d'auteur je pense qu'il a protégé nos
artistes
je pensais ce que fait bruno le maire
par exemple sur la taxation des gaffes à
tout cela ce sont des actions concrètes
menées au niveau européen par la france
leader justement pour réaffirmer que
l'europe peut protéger les personnes
alors voilà il y en a
besoin de protection en france sur
d'autres domaines notamment sur le
terrain économique
justement on parlait de problèmes
d'impopularité est là depuis quelques
jours on sent une contestation qui
grandit par rapport aux prix à la pompe
du à la fiscalité écologique est au
choix de ce gouvernement
est-ce que vous madame busan vous
redoutez cette journée du 17 novembre et
cette mobilisation de cette journée
morte et ce mouvement des gilets jaunes
qui commence à se former
je suis toujours redouté
quelque part les mouvements d'une
société il faut les écouter surtout il
faut comprendre les ressorts
mais il ya une instrumentalisation parce
que il ya une instrumentalisation du
grand public par rapport à cette
augmentation des prix du carburant je le
rappelle je suis à venir je vais quand
même rappeler pourquoi c'est une
instrumentalisation 70% aujourd'hui de
la hausse est liée à la hausse du
pétrole
c'est à dire indépendamment de ce que
fait le gouvernement le gouvernement a
que 70% du prix du pétrole à la pompe
cette étape non mais oui mais
aujourd'hui la hausse est à 70% dit à la
hausse du prix du pétrole
là dessus il y à 6,7 je crois centimes
d'euros de taxes supplémentaires sur le
diesel parce qu'il faut que la taxation
du diesel se rapproche de celle de
l'essence et il y à peu près 4 centimes
d'euro sur l'essence
donc il est un astronaute anisation
parce que en fait tout le monde sait que
nous devons faire un effort majeur pour
l'écologie il ya encore deux mois quand
nicolas hulot a quitté le gouvernement
vous a expliqué que le gouvernement
n'avait pas pris la mesure du risque
écologique
nous travaillons pour les générations
futures nous sommes sans nous sommes
inscrits volontairement dans une
direction d'énergie propre et la
taxation est le seul moyen de faire
bouger les comportements faire en sorte
que les français achètent des véhicules
hybrides ou électriques faire en sorte
qu'ils utilisent plus les transports en
commun mineurs a les moyens
véhicules hybrides alors vous le savez
il ya évidemment prime de conversion
aujourd'hui elle est de 2000 euros pour
les foyers non imposables
il y a aujourd'hui deux cent mille
foyers qui ont demandé cette prime à la
conversion 70% sont des foyers non
imposables donc on voit bien que ça
marche et nous travaillons pour une
prime supplémentaire donnée par les
constructeurs automobiles
et surtout ce que les gens doivent se
rendre compte c'est que s'ils achètent
ce type de véhicule il vous consommez
beaucoup et en fait ils vont gagner en
pouvoir d'achat sur l'année de
consommation gagnait face à un prix du
pétrole et du diesel qui augmente de
l'instrumentalisation et le fait de
clients l'instrumentalisation d'abord
moi je n'entends pas beaucoup les verts
et les anciens du parti socialiste qui
prenait la plus d'écologie venir à la
rescousse à la rescousse si vous voulez
parce qu'on est également rappelé que la
taxation de l'essence et du diesel c'est
une façon de réduire la pollution
atmosphérique
c'est la seule façon je rappelle que 30%
29% de la pollution atmosphérique
aujourd'hui que le gaz à effet de serre
29 % des gaz à effet serre sont émis par
les transports et plus de la moitié par
les transports biaudos heureusement ce
jeu voyait alors de 5000 morts
prématurés liés à la pollution 48
minutes et le diesel
je le rappelle depuis 2012 est classé
par l'om est ce comme un cancérigène
certain et nous savons que le diesel
aujourd'hui entraîne des particules
fines dans l'atmosphère augmente le
risque de leucémie aiguë de l'enfant
autour des grands axes routiers tout
cela est démontré
donc à un moment on prend le taureau par
les cornes on dit qu'on veut réduire les
particules fines dans l'atmosphère qu'on
veut réduire l'utilisation du diesel qui
est un cancérogène prouver les français
n'y sont pour rien et je le comprends
mais on va les accompagner dans cette
transition
elle se fait progressivement alors un
autre sujet d'actualité
tout simplement le justement face à ce
mécontentement le président a demandé au
gouvernement de plancher sur des mesures
d'accompagnement
c'est tout récent et elles sont
réclamées jusque par certains au sein de
la majorité qu est ce que vous envisagez
avez vous dit alors aujourd'hui je les
dis dans mon travail avec les
constructeurs pour accompagner la prime
de conversion un autre type de primes
est donc évidemment je ne suis pas
aujourd'hui ministre des transports donc
je ne peux pas vous donner les pistes
sur lequel travaille
elisabeth bornes ou françois de rugy
mais ce qui compte c'est
l'accompagnement mais la trajectoire les
français doivent comprendre qu'il n'y en
a pas d'autre il n'y en a pas d'autre
nous devons réduire nos gaz à effet de
serre nous devons travailler pour les
populaires pour la future génération
il y a un coût de ces particules fines
un coup de santé publique majeur un coût
environnemental majeur est en fait les
français le savent très bien que nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que de faire
cette transition écologique de nos
énergies
d'accord alors vous parlez de la santé
publique on va parler des pesticides
parce que le sujet est au coeur de
l'actualité d'ailleurs on appris
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait une
interdiction des produits à base de
méthodes sodium pourquoi on peut le
faire pour ce produit là et pas pour le
glyphosate parce que le méthane fabien
sodium pardon entraîner des
intoxications aiguës chez 70 personnes
il y a je crois un mois à peu près
qu'une enquête a été menée c'est un
produit qu'on connaît mal et donc il a
été décidé de stopper pour comprendre
mieux
voilà à quoi était due ces intoxications
et donc c'est vraiment là un principe de
précaution par rapport à une
intoxication aiguë avéré lors d'un
épandage donc avec une très forte
toxicité aiguë mais il ya des
scientifiques qui vous disent il faut
avoir la même attitude avec les autres
pesticides avec ce qu'ils ont on a
découvert dans l'ain avec le nombre de
ses bébés laurent alors on ne va pas là
aussi il faut faire la part des deux
sujets le sujet séparément les
pesticides sont un vrai sujet dans notre
environnement
il y en a de nombreux très nombreux en
fait on ne connaît pas toujours les
effets toxiques de chacun donc avant de
prendre une décision d'interdiction il
faut mieux connaître les faits de chaque
produit vous demande
wolf didier guillaume chezeaud l'année
enfin comme tout le monde je demande
toujours des preuves
enfin ça c'est c'est normal de demander
des preuves faut surtout je vais vous
dire en tant que mise de la santé il
faut aussi que les alternatives qu'on
propose ne soit pas plus toxique que ce
qu'on supprime et donc il ya quand même
un travail de recherche un travail
scientifique est à faire pour être
certain que quand on passe d'un produit
à un autre on ne va pas en réalité avoir
d'autres problèmes de santé donc il ya
un temps d'étude sur le glyphosate le
glyphosate est classé cancérigène
probable de grade 2 b par le hamas donc
moins moins évident que le diesel même
si un risque probable est donc
aujourd'hui la france s'est engagée à
sortir en trois ans dit glyphosate pour
laisser aux agriculteurs trois ans de
transition pour trouver des produits
alternatifs
c'est juste je pense raisonnable comme
attitude
après vont parler des bébés sans bras
aujourd'hui nous cherchons la cause
aujourd'hui c'était bon sens votre
retard aujourd'hui pour la trouver cette
cause parce qu'il ya tellement de
cafouillages de contretemps alors
cafouille alors oui peut-être je vous
rappelle l'histoire l'agent santé
publique france avait dit un temps
maintenant et circulez ya rien à voir
umanis et attendrissement un peu
différent en disant il faut chercher une
cause dont elle a cherché là
d'abord ce sont des enfants vous le
rappeler qu'ils sont nés entre 2000 et
2014 il y a en france chaque année
environ 150 enfants qui naissent avec
des malformations des membres là ce qu'a
vu l' agence et donc les registres qui
sont gérés par l' agence de santé
publique c'est qu'il ya eu un excès de
cas dans deux départements le morbihan
et la loire atlantique et un excès de
cas dans l'ain les scientifiques ne sont
pas d'accord pour dire s'il y avait eu
ou pas ce qu'a fait sentir santé
publique france et qu'elle a été voir
toutes les familles pour essayer de
trouver des causes communes
elle n'a pas dit circulez ya rien à voir
elle a dit je n'ai pas trouvé la cause
commune à ces familles n'ont pas trouvé
donc ce que j'ai décidé de faire avec
françois de rugy
aujourd'hui c'est de relancer une
nouvelle enquête avec non seulement
santé publique france qui connaît bien
la santé et avec land c'est ce qui est
l' agence de l'environnement
risques environnementaux en me disant
que peut-être que deux agences qui ont
des cultures différentes et culture
scientifique de différentes vont
peut-être trouver la cause que santé
publique france n'avait pas trouvé à
l'époque
voilà justement vous parliez des anciens
responsables
écolo ou même du parti socialiste qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ségolène royal
l'ancienne ministre qui hier a estimé
que le gouvernement n'était pas à la
hauteur sur ce sujet et qui est là votre
place aurait dépêché tout de suite des
enquêteurs pour trouver cette cause
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez d'accès
justement ce que j'ai fait donc je ne
comprends pas non madame ségolène royal
a envie d'exister de nouveau je le
comprends chacun à son agenda politique
elle a le sien
donc elle s'empare de ça je rappelle qui
a été ministre de l'environnement je
n'ai pas vu beaucoup parlé de ça dans
les années 2000 2014 à l'époque où il y
avait des cas et des naissances soyons
clairs aujourd'hui c'est exactement ce
que j'ai fait j'ai relancé une enquête
en demandera deux agences de l'état
d'aller retourner vers les familles pour
essayer de reconcevoir le les dossiers
d'essayer de trouver une cause donc je
ne vois pas en quoi nous n'avons pas
pris la mesure de cette voie là cet
événement quand est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à des résultats donc le temps
d'aller voir toutes les familles et de
faire des interrogatoires de retracer
leur vie savoir où elles ont habité
pendant qu'une femme est enceinte ce
qu'elles ont mangé ce qu'elles ont vu
qu'elles ont respiré et ce qu'elles ont
voilà il faut à peu près deux mois et
donc j'ai demandé un rapport un premier
rapport d'étape pour le 31 janvier c'est
le temps qu'il faut pour aller voir les
familles les recontacter et faire des
enquêtes approfondies sur l'histoire de
ces familles parce que oui vous avez
parlé des registres
c'est pas très clair pourquoi les
lanceurs d'alert du registre des
malformations congénitales de rhône
alpes ont ils reçu leur lettre de
licenciement
alors là aussi je suis obligé de faire
un tout petit peu d'histoire
les registres sont financés par
différents fonds c'est souvent des
associations qui tiennent les registres
et ils sont animés par l' agence de
santé publique
ils ont comme mission de surveiller le
territoire pour les maladies donc il
existe des registres des malformations
congénitales
un registre du cancer des registres pour
toutes les maladies il existe des
registres qui nous permet de voir s'il
apparaît des cas en excès et c'est sur
les malformations il ya six registre si
registre qui couvre à peu près 20% du
territoire français il y en a un qui
posait des problèmes scientifiques
puisque plusieurs fois il a échoué à
avoir un label scientifique
les registres sont évalués points pour
leur qualité scientifique et donc du
fait qu'il n'avait pas ce label
les financements ont diminué et donc
elle a failli être licenciés sur des
critères économiques
moi j'ai dit qu'il fallait que là c'est
l'ensemble des registres maintenue nous
avons donc maintenu le financement et
donc le registre va perdurer
il est pérenne et donc la lettre de
licenciement a été retirée puisqu'il n'y
a plus de risque économique ce rejet
mais il va falloir qu'il atteigne le
niveau scientifique et demandes d'actes
à lettres de licenciement été retirés
voilà ça c'est une information assez son
âne employeurs qu'ils avalent à
l'habitat est ce que vous saurez la
ministre de la santé qui sera réussir le
carnet santé numérique vous savez le
relancer demain tous vos prédécesseurs
depuis 15 ans se sont cassé les dents
sur ce projet qui doit faciliter la vie
des patients et leur traitement
alors je vais rendre hommage à mes
prédécesseurs c'est grâce à leurs échecs
successifs que je vais peut-être réussir
en tous les cas on l'a compris de ses
échecs ce qu'ils disent fonctionner
aujourd'hui ce dossier a été confié à
l'assurance maladie qui la mène à bien
depuis plusieurs années demain nous le
déployant sur tout le territoire mais il
a déjà été déployée sur plusieurs
départements dont 50 millions de tonnes
voilà mais nous avons déjà 1 millions de
carnets ouvert de dossier médical
partagé ça va être un outil très
important de communication entre les
professionnels et donc je demande à tous
les français d'aller se faire ouvrir ce
dossier médical soit sur internet sur le
site ameli de l'assurance maladie on est
en tapant dossier médical partagé ou mon
dossier médical et soit chez leur
pharmacien les pharmaciens peuvent aider
les français à ouvrir
le dossier médical ce qui est les
français choisissent les médecins ou les
kinés ou des infirmières qui auront
accès et donc c'est eux qui choisissent
leur professionnel de santé autorisés à
l'ird aussi bloqué ce qu'on vous demande
également aux médecins généralistes de
jouer le jeu et de sa de s'adapter à
cette nouvelle pratique
je crois qu'ils sont très demandeurs en
fait parce que c'est un outil pour eux
comme pour les autres professionnels
ça permet d'éviter de faire des actes de
foi parce qu'on n'a pas un résultat ça
permet de savoir tous les actes qui ont
été réalisés chez un patient même s'il a
été vu en urgence dans une autre région
ça permet en fait de centraliser tout le
dossier médical ça permet de faire des
dégâts aussi parce que vous écoutez gain
de temps où les économies notables
économies
oui ça rationnelle mais souvent les
actes aux inutiles en où tu voyais ça
fait partie ça fait partie de la
sécuriser oui mais ça permet aussi aux
médecins de mieux connaître des
antécédents par exemple vous recevez un
patient un noeud en urgence parce qu'il
est venu passer des vacances dans un
autre département vous avez accès à son
dossier ce n'est que le montant des
économies
non pas du tout le dossier qu'a partagé
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est avant d'être
un outil d'économies c'est un outil de
partage d'informations pour faire d'un
neuer médecine c'est la sécurité des
soins vient l'heure de la deuxième
partie et d'auditions publiques merci
mesdames nous allons accueillir
maintenant les deux parlementaires
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames donc avec nous ce soir
la députée socialiste du gers gisèle
biémouret pour soi c'est à un côté donc
la sénatrice centriste de mayenne
élisabeth doineau bas d'abord madame oui
mais si merci si vous voulez bien madame
la ministre alors bonjour et la question
je suis élu d'un département très rural
dont l' angoisse des déserts médicaux
les difficultés que nous avons pour le
recrutement de mais de celle que ce soit
à l'hôpital public où des médecins de
ville est devenue très compliquée avec
des médecins dans la moyenne d'âge est
proche de l'âge de la retraite dans tout
cela est très angoissant pour la
population pour les élus évidemment qui
se sont énormément de soucis et qui
essaie de recruter des médecins certains
au travers de cabinet de recrutement qui
coûte très cher pour des petites
communes qui n'ont pas toujours des
moyens extensible mais chacun pense à sa
population une population vieillissante
dont moi ma question
madame la ministre et le groupe
socialiste et apparentés avec des pauses
et on
une ppl concernant
là comment dire essayer de réguler
l'installation des médecins
je ne parle pas de contrainte je parle
de régulation et cette ppl a été rejetée
moi je l'enlèverai position de loin
voilà ces deux propositions de loi parle
dans et c'est même assez ma question
parce que c'est ces jeux c'est très aigu
pour nous c'est vraiment le même si nous
essayons de mettre en place beaucoup de
choses
nous essayons mais nous n'y arrivons pas
et voilà la question
alors c'est un sujet extrêmement
douloureux pour les élus et franchement
je respecte profondément cette bataille
que vous menez sur le terrain les maires
pour essayer de recruter des médecins
donc ma réponse elle est très sincère je
pense que la proposition de loi
n'apporte pas la bonne solution pour une
raison que je vous ai exposé au
parlement mais je souhaite peut-être
rappeler devant les auditeurs
aujourd'hui nous héritons d'une
situation assez dramatique nous n'avons
pas anticipé deux choses d'une part le
nombre de médecins nécessaires avec un
exercice médical qui s'est transformé
des médecins qui veulent mieux concilier
leur vie ferme bien des professionnels
qui travaillent pas moins d'heures qui
avec une profession qui s'est beaucoup
féminisée avec des femmes qui veulent
plus d'exercices salariés qui ont
souvent fondé une famille au moment où
elles terminent leurs études et leur
internat donc elles sont pas forcément
très mobiles pour aller s'installer
voilà dans des territoires en difficulté
il faut le dire donc c'est des problèmes
plus généraux conseils territoire pas
seulement les médecins et donc il faut
faire avec un nombre de médecins
alors ils sont nombreux en fait les
médecins en termes de nombre mais
entendre en temps médical dédié aux
malades
ce temps médical est insuffisant par
rapport aux besoins de la population et
on n'a pas anticipé et ça gérer de ça il
faut quinze ans pour former un médecin
et dans les années 90 2000 on n'a pas
anticipé les besoins donc jusqu'en 2025
on va avoir des difficultés à trouver du
temps médical
accessible la deuxième particularité
c'est que les besoins de santé de la
population se sont transformés nous
avons beaucoup de personnes âgées avec
des maladies chroniques ce qui n'était
pas le cas quand on a organisé la
médecine il ya 30 ou 40 ans où les gens
avaient surtout des maladies aiguës des
accidents du travail
donc j'ai proposé une réforme de la
médecine de proximité
je veux que d'autres professionnels de
santé interviennent pour prendre en
charge les malades chroniques des
infirmières des pharmaciens des
kinésithérapeutes comme ça se fait dans
d'autres pays
les médecins n'ont pas besoin de revoir
tous les mois leurs malades chroniques
un certain nombre d'actes de suivi
peuvent être faits par d'autres et donc
mon idée c'est de libérer du temps de
médecins et d'autre part c'est doit
forcément des médecins espèces enfin on
élargit sans voilà peut-être mesdames il
faut être une fonction voilà l'homme
parfait parce que maintenant vous avez
une une enquête sur le terrain alors une
enquête ces petites terres et puis y'a
rien moi je crois que bouna mépor oui
que prononcer ici celui meiser le terme
de désert médical et est absolument
épouvantable parce que c'est
effectivement à terme qu'il va pas
attirer les nouvelles générations de
médecins ou d'autres professionnels de
santé et j'ai tendance à dire que ce
n'est pas un terme sexy en tout cas pour
les jeunes général la réponse de la
ministre élargit en fait le nombre
d'intervenants en matière de santé par
forcément des médecins m des maladies
chroniques et pharmacie me disait que
j'avais pu mener une enquête c'est pas
tout à fait ça d'abord je n'étais pas
seul puisqu'il y avait deux mais ça mais
côté un député thomas chiner et puis le
docteur sophie aux gros qui était très
engagé sur le plan de syndicalistes et
nous avons été sur les territoires les
plus justement en mal de professionnels
de santé et de médecins ce que nous
avons observé c'est que ses dents et à
partir des territoires les plus fragiles
concrets les situations les plus
innovantes les propositions les plus
innovantes
les ministres ont fait la loue
conviennent mais bon je suis en avait à
faire je pense que c'est ce qui serait
encore mieux c'est
de prendre toutes les préconisations du
rapport que nous avons remis il ya
quelques semaines qui est là pour
justement lever tous les irritants
inquiets ont été observés et qui est
finalement empêche certains de médecins
par exemple de monter un cabinet
secondaire parce qu'ils ont la taxe
foncière à payer dans le cabinet
secondaire en plus de celles qu'ils
payent dans le territoire dans lequel
ils ont leur cabinet principal
donc c'est plein de petits irritants
comme ça que nous aimerions voir évoluer
et mais non mais non c'est pas le
président parce qu'il ya là qu'en fait
nous travaillons ensemble ce que nous
avons fait j'ai fait un plan pour
accélérer l'accès aux soins en proximité
donc c'était un plan d'urgence que j'ai
fait l'année dernière avant de vraiment
faire cette transformation du système de
santé qui va se mettre en place cette
année
l'idée c'était vraiment de redonner du
temps médical dans les territoires de
plus en difficulté quitte à ce que des
médecins de certains hôpitaux à et
donner une journée par semaine dans des
maisons de santé ou dans des chais
déchets des médecins libéraux qui
prendraient leur retraite et j'ai
demandé effectivement à des délégués
dont madame la sénatrice doisneau fait
partie avec le docteur thomas meunier et
saufs you grow qui est médecin
généraliste leur ai demandé d'aller sur
les territoires voir comment se mettait
en place le plan est de me faire un
rapport pour que j'améliore encore les
propositions de qu'en réalité le rapport
mme st j'instruis leurs propositions et
j'essaie de lever les verrous pour
faciliter l'installation des jeunes
médecins justement dans les territoires
sachant qu'un certain nombre de ces un
certain nombre de mesures ont déjà été
prises lors du la loi de finances de
2010 8 et qu' un certain nombre de
mesures sont proposées dans cette loi de
finances donc on avance
moi je veux dire surtout que cette
expérience m'a permis de voir combien
les élus sur les territoires
s'investissent mais il faut un véritable
dialogue avec les professionnels de
santé avec les institutions et notamment
les ars parce que c'est indispensable de
considérer l'ensemble de ces
propositions de deux mois pour y
intervenir sur un autre problème aigu
c'est celui des urgences
oui elle est enfin c'est à dire que moi
je suis dans un département qui doit
être atypiques avec une complexité et
des difficultés qui ne sont qui ne sont
pas dû seulement on manque de médecins
urgentistes pour être honnête je veux
poser les choses voilà telles qu'elles
sont mais effectivement nous sommes
on manque de médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital d'auch ch et par ricochet
l'hôpital de condom dans l'hôpital je
vois là je suis au conseil de
surveillance et nous avons été obligés
cette année de fermer
la ligne smur la nuit alors je sais bien
que la directrice de la rs nous a dit
mais il ya très peu de d'urgence vitale
sauf que tout cela est ressenti comme
l'abandon lorsque vous avez la linge
c'est l'injustice qui aiment nos
populations
c'est à dire on avait des urgences elle
fonctionnait avec la ligne ce mur tout
était tout ce passé le mieux possible et
puis tout d'un coup depuis deux trois
ans voilà ça fonctionne daniel font mal
à faire mieux que les services d'urgence
la nuit c'est supra une volonté de
fermer des urgences kiffe mais c'est une
réalité mais à la télé réalité quelque
part que je subis quel alors je suis dit
mais sur lequel j'ai des réponses à
apporter à madame la députée biémouret
en réalité nous n'avons pas formés à ces
d'urgentistes donc par rapport aux 650
services d'urgence existant aujourd'hui
en france nous n'avons pas le nombre de
médecins urgentistes suffisant pour
accueillir les 20 millions de passages
aux urgences par an donc il y à certains
services qui ont des difficultés pour
faire tourner un service d'urgence 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
il faut huit médecins urgentistes donc
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué et nous
sommes en train de les former puisque
dans l'aisne réforme des études de
médecine on a ouvert des postes d'un
terne
ils vont sortir dans un an ou deux au
nombre de deux ans plus tôt dans deux
ans mais d'ores et déjà nous en voyons
ces jeunes internes se former dans les
territoires nous formons des
généralistes à l'activité d'urgence et
il il ya effectivement quelques hôpitaux
en france où il ya un ou deux passages
la nuit est utilisé 8 urgentistes pour
garder une ligne d'urgence où il ya un
passage c'est quasiment impossible parce
qu'en fait s'amuser de cet argument est
donc non mais donc ce que je fais c'est
que je compte en cela j'essaie de
compenser cela par un meilleur service
de transport et d' alerte donc ça c'est
un travail qu'on fait localement avec l'
agence régionale de santé pour compenser
les services d'urgence qui ferment par
des transports facilité on a en a quand
même
la possibilité puisque les choses ont
avancé depuis plusieurs mois de pouvoir
fonctionner en autonomie
voilà on est en train de présenter un
projet alors c'est vrai que les urgences
de l'hôpital de condom c'est un peu plus
de cette année ce sera un peu plus de
8000 passage dans a mené alors
effectivement c'est juste la limite pour
pouvoir fonctionner on va peut-être
simplement pour rassurer madame débours
est beaucoup d'hôpitaux on trouvait des
solutions avec des organisations
collectives d'air qu'il se mette à trois
quatre hôpitaux pour essayer de sérier
une population un bassin de population
et de permettre à la population peut
être soignée en ceux là encore et encore
un amendement débattus récemment qui
pousse les urgences a renvoyé les
patients chez les généralistes qui s'est
amendement parce que je pense que ce
n'est pas réaliste étant donné qu'il
manque déjà des médecins généralistes
qu'ils ont leur clientèle leur
patientèle ils ne peuvent plus prendre
d'autres d'autres patients donc je me
demande comment ils vont faire
un petit peu comme ça j'en avais parlé
d'ailleurs avec le docteur sophie au
groupe qui a lui même était assez
désemparé
et puis en fait dans l'examen dans le
débat vous avez admis qu'une
expérimentation pouvait en tout cas être
comprises et appliquées sur certains
territoires
ce que je pense c'est que on est on
assiste aujourd'hui à un véritable
changement notre organisation d'ailleurs
la stratégie santé 2022 présenter le
président montre bien qu effectivement
aujourd'hui il faut s'organiser
différemment avec les moyens que nous
avons
et avec une population effectivement qui
vieillit et qu'il ya des maladies
chroniques et donc le problème des
urgences parce que globalement les
urgences elle souffre de quoi surtout du
problème d'engorgement
parce que justement il manque des
médecins sur certains territoires et
c'est maintenant ce que l'on peut
imaginer avec les communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé
c'est de s'organiser de graduer les les
besoins en termes de santé et justement
c'est ce lien entre le premier et le
second recours qui sera favorisée dans
ces communautés
d'accord le madame la sénatrice boubli
interpellé la ministre de la santé de
l'amendement parce que ces vies c'est
tellement facile de ridiculiser un
amendement quelques pas on dit à trop de
gens aux urgences on les renvoie chez
generali sakya pas le généraliste c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus fin que ça en
fait un amendement qui est issue d'un
rapport parlementaire qui est fait par
des parlementaires qui préconisait cette
solution c'est quelque chose qui se fait
dans d'autres pays et l'idée c'est
d'aller dans des territoires où les gens
utilisent trop les urgences par facilité
dans certaines villes où il ya plein de
passages inutiles aux urgences pour
renvoyer les gens vers leur médecin
quand il a pas besoin
c'est pas tout la france partout ça
serait jamais prêt à faire ça dans
l'organisation
la médecine en vue elle sera favorisée
justement à travers les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires à travers les
centres de santé qui proposeront
justement d'accueillir les soins non
programmés
mais c'est vrai que tout ça ne peut pas
se faire en un jour en fait on est dans
un défi collectif est absolument le
réfléchir tous ensemble non moi ici que
ces trans partisan évidemment oui comme
cette réflexion c'est formidable la
sénatrice vous êtes venus pour
interpeller également la ministre sur
une inquiétude que vous avez concernant
le reste à charge 0 eh bien vous avez
une proposition à faire également
concernant les familles monoparentales
d'abord le reste à charge 0 alors sur le
reste à charge généraux c'est vrai que
pour moi c'est une très belle avancée
parce que effectivement beaucoup de
patients renoncer aux soins auditifs
parce que c'était très élevé aux soins
comment visuel est également aux soins
dentaires
mais la difficulté on le voit bien c'est
qu'il ya une angoisse à ce que les
complémentaires en fait augmente soit
l'heure leur coût est l'heure prévue des
genres mais je mange je pense qu'il faut
absolument rassurer les français sur ce
point là parce qu'ils peuvent aussi
baisser leurs forfaits sur d'autres
prestations et ça c'est vraiment aussi
très discret sur la question
alors la question c'est comment il
pouvait déjà joué les français sur le
prix des complémentaires et je voulais
avoir aussi un autre point de vigilance
parce que il se trouve que sur les
prothèses dentaires comme sur les
lunettes on a des fabricants français
or aujourd'hui ils ont vraiment la peur
de licenciés ils ont la peur de ne pas
faire encore du made in france parce que
il y aura certainement recours à des
prothèses asiatiques à des lunettes
aussi bon marché qui viennent du marché
chinois
or nous avons en france des industries
qui fonctionne très bien sur ces
fabriques là et moi je voudrais aussi
que vous leur apporte y est long des
décors des réponses de réponse alors je
vais commencer par la deuxième question
sur les lunettier les fabricants
français du jura qui sont qui ont un
savoir faire
by enfin voilà il y en a il y en a un
certain nombre
c'est une des premières choses que j'ai
demandé à mes services quand on a
commencé à négocier sur le prix et sur
le fait qu'on demandait à tous les
acteurs de la chaîne de production
dentaires lunettes et audioprothèses de
faire des économies sur leurs marges et
donc je voulais être certaine que l'une
pénalise y ont peint nos lunettier
français donc j'ai demandé à mes
services de travailler avec le ministère
de l'industrie
il se trouve que nos lunettier français
font des lunettes de très haut de gamme
très bonne qualité qui en fait ne rentre
pas de facto dans le probablement pas en
reste à charge héros d'autre part je
crois alors j'ai peur de me tromper mais
la majorité de leur production part à
l'étranger
donc en réalité ils seront assez peu
impacté mais c'est du haut de gamme et
donc je rappelle que le reste à charge 0
s'adresse quand même un public vraiment
besoin de ne pas du tout dépensé de sa
poche
on pense qu à peu près 15 à 20% de la
population via y avoir recours la
population la plus précaire mais
évidemment les complémentaires vont
continuer de couvrir en tous les cas une
bonne partie des lunettes plus cher
parce qu'on peut imaginer que des gens
aient envie d'avoir plus de choix et là
évidemment c'est lui métier là ne seront
pas impactés
donc il y aura un libre choix qui
persiste et on a été très attentif à
cette filière donc on peut les rassurer
ils ont fait partie valeur le côté
occupe la sa le prix des complémentaires
ça fait partie ça faisait partie du duo
l'homme du s'inquiète ce moment ça
faisait partie du alors je vous laisse
aujourd'hui c'est une question
effectivement on entend une petite
musique qui dit mais les retraités
risquent de voir leurs complémentaires
eux augmenté puisque ce sont eux qui
entre guillemets consomment le plus de
puces parce que c'est ce que l'on entend
qui est qui qui qui les énerve beaucoup
quand même parce que je trouve que c'est
pas trés c'est un peu humiliant
de parler comme ça parce que certains
certaines parlent comme ça pas vous même
un ministre je ne leur reproche pas mais
effectivement dont on peut s'inquiéter
lisez les airs et les retraités
s'inquiètent je suis sam à toute cette
manne toute cette réforme allait quand
même fait pour que les personnes les
plus en difficultés puissent accéder à
une offre de soins correct donc
évidemment aux foyers les plus modestes
et aux retraités les retraités qui ont
du mal notamment à accéder aux
audioprothèses ce sont les premiers qui
en ont besoin quand même ça ça touche
rarement les jeunes et donc c'est
vraiment pour eux qu'on a fait cette
réforme donc si cette réforme
aboutissait à leur faire payer le prix
de la réforme il n'y serait pas gagnant
donc on a alors après je peux pas être à
cent pour cent sûr qu aucun contrat ne
va pas évoluer par contre sur la
globalité les mutuelles et les assureurs
se sont engagés à ne pas répercuter le
coût il reste à charge héros et pourquoi
ils se sont engagés d'abord parce qu'on
a négocié sur le prix de toute la
filière
donc on a demandé à chacun de faire des
efforts aux opticiens aux producteurs et
donc chacun fait une partie du chemin
pour permettre aux français d'être
équipé ensuite l'assurance maladie prend
les trois quarts du coup sur les 1
milliard d'économies pour les français
trois quarts 750 millions d'euros vont
être directement payés par l'assurance
maladie la sécurité sociale et donc les
mutuelles et des assureurs 250 millions
250 millions à m regarder 37 milliards
qui est leur budget représente 0 14 % de
leur budget vous comprenez bien que
c'est absorbable par une meilleure
gestion et part peut-être d'autres soins
qui pourrait ne pas être aussi bien
remboursé mais nous considérons que ces
sois là sont indispensables évidemment
la santé des français là pour les
réponses
je vais rendre public évidemment je fais
un observatoire des prix des parce que
je veux rend public justement ce que
vont faire les différentes branches
ça sera pour moi évidemment un levier
d'action si je vois des choses dérivés
par rapport à l'accord qui a été signé
mais même chez les volumes habituels
alors un honteux celles qui augmentent
j'ai confiance
elles sont quand même vous avez écouté
énormément six et huit mois
elles se sont engagées et j'ai confiance
merci beaucoup
mesdames d'avoir participé à ce dialogue
avec la ministre de la santé merci vous
allez maintenant la laisser la place à
nos deux consoeurs qui arrivent pour la
dernière partie de l'audition publique
merci monsieur
avec donc oriane mancini de public sénat
et brigitte boucher de lcp assemblée
nationale avec la réaction des
téléspectateurs par exemple sur le site
du figaro il ya miss marie cécile qui
vous demandaient pourquoi est-ce que
vous ne sanctionner par les patients qui
viennent inutilement encombrer les
urgences ou qui appelle le samu pour
rien alors une sanction alors avant de
dire qu'on appelle pour rien il faut
quand même avoir l'avis d'un médecin
c'est compliqué c'est que parfois ça
appellerait des sanctions alors quand
les gens abusent vraiment c'est-à-dire
viennent pour un renouvellement
d'ordonnancé par exemple c'est là où
s'appliquerait justement le fait qu'on
ait réduit vers leur médecin
mais ensuite sanctionné les gens on
prendrait le risque que des gens aient
peur d'aller aux urgences pour avoir une
sanction est donc renoncé prennent des
risques pour leur santé
j'ai toujours peur des dérives si vous
sanctionner les gens que les gens qui
ont mal au ventre ils vont se dire si ça
se pouvait être sanctionnée élise de
palais aux urgences alors qu'ils ont une
vraie urgence et donc on peut pas
prendre ce risque là voilà la réponse à
massy marie-cécile du figaro.fr et
maintenance et oriane oui on va parler
de la pénurie de médicaments depuis 2008
le nombre de médicaments concernés par
des ruptures ou des problèmes
d'approvisionnement été multiplié par 10
en 2010 est l' agence nationale du
médicament reçu 530 signalement de
rupture de stock de difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour des traitements
considérés parfois comme essentielle
comment vous expliquer cette pénurie
alors les raisons sont en fait multiples
il n'y a pas une seule raison il ya
d'abord le fait que l'industrie du
médicament
c'est centralisé il ya de moins en moins
d'industriels et ils ont des zones de
production des lieux de production pour
probablement rationaliser leurs coûts
qui se limite parfois une usine
donc quand il ya un incendie par exemple
dans une usine et bien les usines
ferment en trois mois il ya plus de
production donc il est impératif que les
industriels du médicament nous propose
des plans de gestion de risques c'est ce
qu'on leur demande aujourd'hui on a un
outil légal pour le faire pour nous
expliquer comment ils font silien
difficultés de fabrication
après parfois ça peut être une pénurie
de la substance active qui est issu je
vais vous donner un exemple mais après
l'accident de fukushima il y avait une
substance active d'un médicament qui
étaient issus des poissons et saumon
pêché dans la zone de fukushima
là on ne peut pas faire grand chose et
puis il ya parfois des décisions
d'industriels d'arrêter de fabriquer un
médicament parce qu'il n'est pas
rentable et on les utilise trop peu et
donc qu'est-ce que vous allez un moyen
de pression dont là dessus juste leur
collection intervenir ce qu'il faut
changer la législation alors aujourd'hui
il ya eu un rapport du sénat remarquable
de deux sénateurs un monsieur d'aubigny
monsieur de cool qui de cole pardon qui
propose des pistes sur lequel nous
travaillons nous avons déjà renforcé
notre législation en 2016 avec des
plombs de gestion de risque qui sont
demandés aux industriels ensuite nous il
faut qu'on travaille sur ces médicaments
qui n'intéresse plus industriel est ce
qu'on est capables nous même de les
produire ou est ce qu'on est capable de
les obliger à continuer la production
par exemple de vieux anticancéreux qui
ne leur rapporte plus beaucoup d'argent
parce que c'est 10 euros
la curée qu'ils ont plutôt intérêt à
développer des médicaments très chers
bas par exemple donc et or les deux sont
nécessaires et donc aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas une seule réponse à la pénurie des
médicaments en fait il y a une plume
multitude de levier selon de la cause
par ce rapport du sénat un parmi les
pistes du sénat il ya un site et une
production pharmaceutique sur le
territoire national pour cela le sénat
propose d'expérimenter la mise en place
des exonérations fiscales ou encore le
versement par l'état et les régions des
dalles embauche est ce que ça pour vous
c'est une solution est ce que vous allez
suivre cette préconisation aujourd'hui
tout ce qui allège le coût du travail
quelque part et toutes les réformes que
nous menons sur le coût du travail
permet en fait à des entreprises qui
sont beaucoup américaine en réalité ou
suisse pour l'industrie du médicament
les incite à revenir sur le territoire
français c'est de délocalisation on a
été victimes de délocalisations donc il
ya moins de production
sur est-ce que des malades sont en
danger aujourd'hui pour nous faire de la
vie si par exemple il est possible de ne
pas trouver le médicament pour pour se
soigner et david s'agit d'un médiation
qui doivent renoncer absolument alors il
y à il ya des alternatives qui ont été
mises en place avec en fait ce que fait
l' agence du médicament c'est dès
qu'elles voient qu'une pénurie va
arriver elle travaille avec les
industriels d'un côté pour voir comment
ils vont répondre à cette pénurie et
elle travaille avec les professionnels
pour qu'ils identifient les situations
le médicament est indispensable pour le
réserver aux patients pour lequel il n'y
a pas d'alternative donc tout cela c'est
un travail en continu que fait l'agent
du médicament mais nous travaillons
évidemment sur des pistes favorisant la
réimplantation du sinn en france mais
chaque ville tout ce que nous faisons
sur le coût du travail qui va permettre
une relocalisation des usines est
évidemment quelque chose qui va dans le
bouquet ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quels sont les vaccins qui sont en
rupture de stock vous avez fait voter
une loi pour que onze vaccin sera
obligatoire
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contradictoire finalement alors ce ne
sont pas ces vaccins 20 qui sont en
rupture de stock az circuler en france
alors que c'est quand j'ai fait la loi
j'ai vu tous les industriels et je leur
ai alors le bcg n'est plus obligatoire
c'est un vaccin
c'est un vaccin non non c'est un vaccin
sais même pas qui n'est plus obligatoire
il est réservé a très très peu de cas
aujourd'hui très très peu de cas des
gens migrants qui ont au risque de
tuberculose
donc c'est pas un vaccin qui pose
problème ce qui pose problème c'est
l'hépatite b en monovalent c'est-à-dire
isolé mais celui-là il est simplement
réservé aux professionnels de santé
en réalité j'ai fait très attention à ce
que tout ce qui est obligatoire ne
puisse pas être en rupture de stock vous
plaît tissu normalement les familles de
tout ça que la france a perdu sa
souveraineté
pharmacies alors c'est un problème
international en réalité c'est pas la
france c'est tous les pays du monde qui
souffrent aujourd'hui de pénurie des
médicaments et nous travaillons sur des
actions européennes notamment vis-à-vis
des industries qui ne sont pas en europe
autre sujet bogeys on parle de l'hôpital
un cri d'alarmé a été lancé par les
hôpitaux publics les cliniques privées
le déficit se creuse un milliard en 2010
8,1 milliards en prévisionnel 2010 9
vous baisser les tarifs halak et vous
développez l'ambulatoire baisse des
volumes baisse des tarifs est ce que
c'est pas la double peine et comment
peuvent-ils s'en sortir je ne laisse pas
les tarifs à l'acte avant de dire que je
baisse les tarifs à l'acte je les ai
baissé l'année dernière j'ai surtout
baisser le volume d'actes parce qu'en
fait les hôpitaux font moins d'actes du
fait de l'ambulatoire et de plus de
prise en charge par la médecine de ville
libérale ça c'est un fait donc on a
réduit le nombre d'actes essarts volume
donc ils ont fait moins de volume ce qui
a creusé leur déficit
c'est pour ça que j'ai proposé cette
réorganisation du système de santé qui
vise à recentrer des hôpitaux sur leurs
actes à forte valeur ajoutée pour qu'ils
évitent de se disperser sur tout un tas
d'activités qui peuvent être faites par
d'autres et sur lequel ils ne sont pas
rentables en réalité donc ça c'est un
travail qui va être de longue haleine
évidemment qu'il va se faire sur
plusieurs années avec une gradation des
soins dans les hôpitaux des hôpitaux qui
vont être vraiment des hôpitaux de
proximité dédié aux pathologies
chroniques aux personnes âgées et des
hôpitaux de recours pour des actes plus
complexe pour qu'on rentabilise mieux
les plateaux techniques
tout ça c'est un travail de
réorganisation des hôpitaux que je suis
en train de faire dans ma santé 2022 la
seule bouffée d'oxygène que vous pouvez
leur rappeler je devais lui aussi
arrêtons de financer tout à l'acte parce
que ça pousse à faire des actes inutiles
ya du volume et donc je préfère qu'on
finance au forfait ou à la prise en
charge de population c'est ce qu'on va
mettre en place dès cette année
parce que les hôpitaux sont pas les
aider à réduire le déficit l'innovation
au contraire on va à les valoriser pour
des activités qu'ils font et qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas reconnus et
c'est ça l'objectif c'est aussi de
financer aujourd'hui ce que fait de bien
l'hôpital par exemple les prises en
charges complexes par exemple le fait de
discuter des dossiers à plusieurs
médecins
ça a un coût aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
valorisé donc tout cela va participer
d'une meilleure façon de tahar effet
maintenu alors les ventes de l'état a
été mise sur le chantier note tout à
fait récemment par le premier ministre
vous êtes directement concernée est ce
que
il y aura donc des mesures par exemple
dans les hôpitaux parce que contractuels
alors pour des économies aussi sur
favorise et encourage alors si c'est pas
pour des économies avec aux contractuels
1 c'est pour en réalité répondre à
certaines difficultés je vous donne un
exemple qui se passe à l'armée mais qui
se passe aussi dans nos hôpitaux nous
avons besoin de très bons informaticiens
parfois pour remettre vraiment en oeuvre
la sécurité de nos systèmes où nos
systèmes sont assez vulnérable en termes
de sécurité
on a besoin parfois d'harmoniser
plusieurs hôpitaux en termes d'outils
informatiques de moderniser c'est très
difficile de trouver des fonctionnaires
informaticien et l'armée a même problème
est donc là ça peut être utile d'avoir
accès à des contractuels sur un projet
mise en oeuvre de la sécurité
informatique ça peut durer un an un an
et demi là on a besoin de gens très bien
formés et sur un projet un temps donné
et donc la fonction publique
hospitalière elle est concernée par ce
type de contrat comme les autres
fonctions publiques la fonction publique
d'état
c'est ça la contractualisation c'est pas
fait pour faire des économies c'est pour
faire pour répondre à un besoin
particulier organiquement oui sur la pme
puisque ce week end laurent wauquiez les
présidents de groupes parlementaires les
républicains ont publié une tribune dans
le figaro pour expliquer leur décision
de voter contre la pma pour toutes les
femmes
est ce que vous comprenez leurs points
de vue leurs arguments je comprends
évidemment moi je pense que c'est de
l'ordre de l'intimé je respecte
évidemment les personnes qui ont cette
vision d'une famille bon jeu dans la
dans la loi de bioéthique
la façon dont on veut écrire la
filiation va bien acté qu'il y ait un
père on ne nie pas le père et le père
biologique existe évidemment
et si nous allons vers par exemple
l'accès aux origines des enfants et
pourrir un jour devait damas à la levée
de l'anonymat voudrait dire qu'on
choisit son donneur se vend son nom est
selon la couleur de ses yeux etc doivent
pas tout à fait ça la levée de
l'anonymat en fait elle se fera quand
l'enfant cherche des années voilà alors
si c'est voter évidemment et si nous
allons dans cette direction ça voudrait
dire aussi que l'enfant pourra accéder à
cette figure paternelle sens qu
évidemment ça met en cause
je dirais les droits de succession par
exemple ces donneurs évidemment ne vont
pas se retrouver avec plein d'enfants
c'est simplement ça permettrait de se
construire donc personne ne nie le fait
qu'il ya un père biologique et ça sera
inscrit évidemment dans la façon dont la
filiation sera écrivain entente se
construire mais c'est en vacances ce
sera ma joue ça veut dire que les
parents vont être obligés de le dire
ça évite de nier en fait cette évidence
qu'on a été conçue d'une certaine façon
avec un père biologique et de mère qui
s'occupe de vous et voilà après moi je
voudrais quand même dire tout ce qui si
la tribune vous prouver que je suis
rabelais c'était une de toute façon un
engagement total engagement de campagne
et président de la république donc mais
je sais que c'est vraiment ses promesses
non mais je n'en vends ses débats à ce
débat au parlement et je veux vraiment
qu'ils soient apaisées et que chacun se
respecte
on parle quand même de souffrances
individuelles on parle à la foi de
convictions profondes je les respecte
on parle de souffrance individuelle
profond que je respecte aussi donc voir
ce dernier ce que je veux dire c'est que
joe france des opposants non je passais
des personnes qui ont envie le
s'inscrire dans un projet parental et
qu'ils ne peuvent pas car aujourd'hui
sauf à faire des artifices voilà sur
cette tribune vous savez que
l'inquiétude des opposants à la pma pour
tout c'est que l'apn pour tout
aujourd'hui soit la gpa demain quand les
républicains disent pose cette question
1 comment refuser demain aux couples
d'hommes ce que l'on accorderait aux
couples de femmes la jeunesse que vous
leur répondre et alors je vais
d'ailleurs expliqué en fait et
d'ailleurs chaudat qu'on revienne sur
les autres mesures de la loi de
bioéthique parce que on est tous
focalisés sur la pme est en fait la loi
de bioéthique a énormément de mesures
qui auront un impact fort pour la
population dont on discute pas et qui
quelque part sont des sujets de société
en fait c'est un c'est un petit sujet de
société par rapport aux autres mesures
de la loi de bioéthique dont pâtissent
aussi accessible c'est pour moi c'est un
énorme regret qu'on se focalise comme ça
sur quelque chose qui va concerner
peut-être quelques milliers de femmes
alors qu'il y à des sujets dans la veine
poétique qui vont potentiellement
toucher des millions de français je
pense à toutes les questions sur la
génétique par exemple jusqu'où en vain
dans les analyses génétiques dans la
liberté etc
et ça c'est beaucoup plus impactants
quelque part je dirais plus intéressant
mais bon sur la gpa je vais revenir
parce que des lois de bioéthique
c'est en fait faire des choix entre des
valeurs qui se confrontent
or il ya des valeurs fondamentales comme
celle de la liberté et ça c'est la pma
pays une autre valeur fondamentale qui
est celle de l'intégrité du corps humain
le fait qu'on ne marchandises par le
corps humain qui ne soit pas l'objet
d'un contrat marchand et cette valeur là
elle est supérieure à la valeur de la
liberté et donc elle gagnera par rapport
à la valeur de la liberté
quelque part le fait d'autoriser la pma
ne n'engendre pas un glissement vers
l'âge et perd parce que c'est d'autres
choses qu'il faut accepter si on
acceptait la gpa pour lequel aujourd'hui
nos lois de bioéthique française ne sont
absolument pas prêt
le gîte est ce que la sécurité sociale
doit rembourser la pma pour toutes
alors ça fera partie du débat vous votre
ado six mois on verra comment nous
l'écrivons parce que nous avons encore
un peu de travail à faire avec les
parlementaires
il ya un groupe on est en train de
travailler afin de réfléchir à comment
vous chercher quand même mais on sent
qu'il ya peut-être un doute qui vous
saisit en tous les cas le chef de l'état
puisque vous cherchez pas c'est une très
mauvaise interprétation ça c'est pas un
doute c'est qu'en réalité
non mais c'est une mauvais
interprétation parce que un doute
voudrait dire qu'on doute là un sujet
explosif et qu' est-ce que vous êtes
focalisé sur la pma en est la raison
pour laquelle moi je vais travailler
avec les parlementaires c'est pas sur la
pme ce que la pma quelque part on a
tranché mais c'est sur le reste et le
reste est éminemment technique et on ne
peut pas arriver avec des mesures aussi
compliquée techniquement à comprendre
dans un débat parlementaire sans avoir
préparé en amont revenir là dessus parce
que quand vous parlez de discussions
avec les parlementaires on sait que le
calendrier parlementaire est très chargé
en 2019 est ce que ce projet de loi sera
bien au parlement 2019 sur vous nous
confirmez faudra pas attendre 2020 pour
son adoption
non aujourd'hui les programmes et en
2010 mais d'autres sujets on va parler à
de la colère des ambulanciers qui
manifestaient aujourd'hui contre
l'article 81 du projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale c'est le
financement des transports sanitaires il
ya les hôpitaux qui pourront choisir les
ambulanciers à la place des patients
eux-mêmes donc via des appels d'offres
donc certains craignent pour leur
profession une forme dubé risation de
ces pme ambulanciers qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez alors d'abord j'ai été
très vigilante à ne pas favoriser dubé
risation et à protéger
contrairement à ce qu ils peuvent penser
à protéger aujourd'hui une profession
qui est celle des ambulanciers d'un
risque d'ubs et risation par contre nous
voyons dans les dépenses d'assurance
maladie aujourd'hui les dépenses de
transports ou considérablement augmenté
d'année en année et donc ce que nous
avons proposé aux hôpitaux dans cet
article 80 qui met en colère les
ambulanciers mais on va on va continuer
à travailler avec eux évidemment
c'est que je demande aux hôpitaux
d'essayer de rationaliser les transports
entre hôpitaux aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
pas obligé enfin quand vous êtes un
hôpital et que vous vous prescrivez un
transport sanitaire
chacun peut choisir son ambulance et ça
va être remboursée par la sécurité
sociale là nous proposons que un hôpital
qui aurait par exemple deux malades
venant d'un même village puisse dire
mais non je prend en charge le transport
donc on a mis ça dans le budget des
hôpitaux mais je rationalise donc c'est
une façon de rationaliser voiturage
medica s'est pas de libéralisation c'est
d'une rationalisation deux minutes
alors on va essayer de traiter de sujets
très rapide un mot sur le vin puisque
l'année dernière c'est un sujet sensible
un levain en france c'est un sujet
compliqué la dernière que vous avez
déclaré que le vin était un alcool comme
les autres vous êtes attirée les foudres
des défenseurs du vin titi guillaume le
nouveau ministre de l'agriculture a
exclu toute augmentation des taxes sur
le vin est ce que vous le regrettez non
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas ma bataille
aujourd'hui ma bataille j'en ai deux
c'est l'alcool chez les femmes enceintes
les femmes enceintes ne savent pas qu'il
ne faut rien boire pas un verre et donc
c'est la première chose que je veux
faire passer à la population c'est pas
de tabac pas d'alcool pendant la
grossesse parce que ça met en danger le
foetus
il ya un enfant par jour en france qui
naît d'un syndrome d'alcoolisation
foetale c'est à dire avec un handicap
ça c'est ma première bataille de la
deuxième c'est le binge drinking des
jeunes et ne se fait pas avec du vin
malheureusement ou heureusement
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas ce qu'il se
fait avec des alcools forts et c'est
devenu un phénomène de société il y a
des morts
et ça c'est insupportable et donc nous
travaillons à une meilleure prévention
et une meilleure prise en compte
aujourd'hui des jeunes qui auront été
dans le coma par exemple hospitalisé
avec un suivi psychologique obligatoire
derrière alors votre autre combat c'est
bien sûr le tabac je signale que c'est
le mois sans tabac dernière question
d'actualité sur le levothyrox le
tribunal de grande instance de toulouse
ordonne des expertises médicales est ce
que le ministère de la santé a pris
toutes les précautions avant de mettre
sur le marché son médicament cette
nouvelle formule pour ça il faudrait
non c'est pas bien ce que je vais dire
je vais demander à marisol touraine
puisqu'en fait la mise en oeuvre sur le
marché s'est faite en avril avant qu'on
soit en plus président de la république
soit élu
mais franchement oui je crois que je
suis je n'ai pas là il ya eu un énorme
problème d'information des malades et
des médecins qui n'ont pas pris la
mesure du changement de formuler des
risques ce que ça pouvait faire encourir
aux malades en termes de doses
il ya eu une incompréhension je pense
des patients du fait qu'ils n'étaient
pas mis au courant mais parce qu'en fait
la loi française telle qu'elle est
rédigé aujourd'hui n'oblige personne à
prévenir les passions mais la justice
s'en mêle alors mais face à cela la
demande des patients des patients
demandent en fait une compensation pour
le préjudice subi et je trouve ça normal
que la justice fasse son travail je ne
mêle pas
évidemment déçu merci beaucoup madame la
ministre d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui au cours de sept heures
d'auditions publiques vont se fermer
dame bonsoir à tous et la semaine
prochaine